Oh.
Are we on?
Um, we're on?
OK.
Well, um, hi.
Hi.
I'm Pete Monster, a
developer advocate at Google,
and I think the
internet is for forms.
Forms are a pain to fill
out, especially on mobile.
Keyboards are small, you
have to switch between them,
monsters are impatient,
and with our furry thumbs,
it's hard to hit the right key.
It isn't a surprise that almost
97% of mobile shopping carts
are abandoned.
I've got a few tips
to improve your forms,
reducing the pain
for your monsters,
and increasing the chances
that they'll get it right.
Take the pain out
of forms by reducing
the number of
questions that you ask.
And be sure to label and
name your inputs properly.
Use the label element to
provide direction to monsters,
telling them what
information is needed.
Each label is
associated with an input
by placing it inside
the label element,
or by using the for attribute.
Using labels also helps to
improve touch target sizes.
Monsters can either touch
the label or the input
and immediately start typing.
Yay!
Placeholders give hints
about the expected input.
Adding a placeholder attribute
will display its value
as light text until
the element gets focus.
Best of all, it's all done
automagically by the browser
with no extra
javascript required.
Yay!
But you know what's even better
than an input with a large tap
target?
Well, do you?
Tell me.
I'm waiting.
Still waiting.
OK, fine.
I'll tell you.
Having the browser
do it for you.
Yay!
Don't use random values
for input names or IDs.
Instead, use standard
naming conventions.
For example, want the
monster's first name?
Name the input fname.
In cases where the browser
can't fill it in automagically,
that makes monster mad.
Hmph!
Tell the browser
which keyboard will
be the most useful by using
the correct input type.
These new input types
give hints to the browser
about what type of
keyboard layout to use.
That makes it easier
to enter information
without having to
change the keyboard,
and monsters only see the
appropriate keys for that input
type.
Monsters and humans
love feedback,
so keep them up-to-date
as they fill the form in.
And before they submit it,
make sure everything is A-OK.
Don't make them wait until
the form has been submitted
to tell them they
forgot something.
Tell them right away!
There are several
attributes that you
can use to provide
monster side validation.
The pattern attribute
specifies a regular expression
used to validate an input field.
If the required
attribute is present,
then the field must
contain a value
before the form
can be submitted.
For numeric input types like
numbers, ranges, dates, times,
you can specify the
minimum and maximum values,
as well as how much they should
each increment or decrement,
as they're adjusted by
the sliders or spinners.
The maxlength
attribute can be used
to specify the
maximum input length,
and is useful when you want to
limit the length of information
provided by the monster.
But when built-in validation
and regular expressions
aren't enough, you can use
the constraint validation API,
a powerful tool for
handling custom validation.
To make sure the form is
valid before it's submitted,
catch the submit event and
then use the checkValidity
function to make sure
that everything is A-OK.
If not, prevent the form
from being submitted,
and tell the monster
about all the problems.
Otherwise, submit away.
Yay!
The best forms have
the fewest inputs,
are easy to understand,
have large tap targets,
use the right keyboards, and
give monsters lots of feedback.
Do your forms follow all
these best practices?
If not, get on it.
And once you've done that,
check out this other video
on how request
autocomplete can help
eliminate checkout
forms completely.
Thanks for watching.
Bye!
Are we off?
Are we done yet?
Why are you still watching?
I'm done.
I don't have
anything more to say.
Honest.
You can go now.
This isn't like
one of those movies
where there's a surprise ending.
We're done.
OK, I'm just going to leave now.
See ya.